now we go to Capitol Hill for the first
major hearing from the house oversight
committee this featuring several fired
Twitter Executives as a reminder there
was ample evidence of collusion in the
2020 election uh but not between Trump
and Russia instead Twitter Facebook
Google other big tech companies uh were
coordinating collaborating with not only
the DNC the Biden campaign but the upper
echelon of your FBI all United in one
effort they wanted to defeat Donald J
Trump and help elect Joe Biden now the
first example of this involves a very
true Hunter Biden laptop story from Hell
in the New York Post they broke the
story weeks before the 2020 election you
know companies like Twitter they were
more than happy to to tweet out and not
tweet out that which was being told to
them take a look Mr Roth did the
government tell you that the Biden
laptop story was fake
no sir they did not they tell you it was
hacked no sir they did not so the FBI
didn't tell you uh that that it was fake
didn't tell you that it was hacked uh
and and Mr Roth did the did the story
violate your policies
in my judgment at the time no it did not
yeah that's what you said said what I
would propose excuse me as you said it
isn't clearly a violation of our hack
materials policy nor is it clearly a
violation of anything else
so I think what a lot of people are
wondering is if it didn't violate your
policies
and they didn't tell you it was fake
didn't tell you it was hacked why'd you
take it down
the company made a decision that found
that it did violate the policy I think
you guys wanted to take it down I think
you guys got played by the FBI and
that's the scary part
now Twitter other big Tech they eagerly
censored the New York posts America's
oldest newspaper because of their blind
rage against Donald Trump evidence that
in fact they've been politicized in
their own right working with the FBI
having weekly meetings pretty pretty
insane to even think about they weren't
capable of being fair balanced objective
don't believe me you decide Mr Roth did
you write this tweet
I regret the language that I used in
some of my former tweets but yes I did
post that and I'll read the Tweet so
it's in the record yes that person in
the pink hat is clearly a bigger threat
to your brand of feminism than actual
Nazis in the White House
Mr Roth do you think all conservatives
are Nazis
certainly not sir
what about the hundreds of people who
worked in the Trump Administration
certainly not
all right that was the former head of
quote site integrity at Twitter a guy by
the name a person by the name of Joel
Roth calling Republicans Nazis on
Twitter uh at the very same time Roth
was participating in an effort to block
and censor Republicans for just about
anything all while dangerous criminals
you know acted with impunity take a look
at this you abused the power of a large
corporation big Tech to censor Americans
and you want to know something guess
what I'm so glad that you're censored
down I'm so glad you've lost your jobs
you permanently banned my Twitter
account but you allowed child child porn
all over Twitter what were my tweets
okay let's talk about them I was talking
about the deaths being reported on bears
by the way that's on the CDC website
I was also saying that I didn't think
the any entity should enforce a non-da
non-fda approved vaccine or mask
guess what a lot of people agreed with
me but you called that coveted
misinformation by the way I'm a member
of Congress and you're not
I also said the controversial coveted 19
vaccines should not be forced on our
military you want to know something
Republicans stop that in the ndaa
now while actual Predators continue to
operate on Twitter the FBI was meeting
weekly with big tech companies to
supposedly protect them against
so-called misinformation campaigns in
the lead-up to the 2020 election the
lead agent even wrote his thesis
apparently about his theory that Donald
Trump in fact did collude with Russia to
beat Hillary Clinton in the 2016
election something that has been totally
and completely debunked and remember the
FBI had the laptop they had it since
2019 in December they also knew that
Rudy Giuliani had a copy of it which
means they also knew the likelihood was
high that it would come out and they had
plenty of time to authenticate it all
themselves did they do it maybe if so
they didn't tell us according to
congresswoman though Alexandria
ocasio-cortez this is all a do about
nothing she called the Hunter Biden
laptop Scandal half fake and demanded
demanded we talk about more important
things than our government colluding
with big Tech to influence an election
and prevent people from getting the
information that might in fact sway them
in terms of who they want to vote for
information that's important take a look
a whole hearing about a 24-hour hiccup
in a right-wing political operation that
is why we are here right now and it is
it's just an abuse of public resources
and abuse of public time we could be
talking about health care we could be
talking about bringing down the cost of
prescription drugs we could be talking
about abortion rights Civil Rights
Voting Rights but instead we're talking
about Hunter Biden's half fake laptop
Story I mean this is an embarrassment
all right forget the noise what Twitter
did in the fall of 2020 for Joe Biden
was the in-kind donation of in-kind
donations so big that you could actually
never measure the amount of dollars that
would have cost somebody to buy that
kind of uh information suppression they
censored a scandal that could have
turned the entire election they shut
down accounts of prominent Republicans
they Shadow ban conservatives at every
opportunity and in some cases it appears
they were working on behalf of the FBI
directly that's not just unethical that
would be illegal hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else